The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Because
some of this course
was shot in two different years,
two different notations systems
were used.
And I'm going to
explain both of them
so that when you encounter
them in the videos
of the recitations of the
videos of the lectures,
you'll be able to use either
of the notation systems
interchangeably.
So the two notation
systems would
refer to how we explain position
vectors, velocity vectors,
and vectors of any
kind that might
be associated with translating
and rotating reference frames.
So in this diagram,
I've got a rigid body.
And attached to that rigid
body is a reference frame.
I'll call it XYZ.
Attached and moves
with the body.
And that's reference frame AXYZ.
And the whole system is
translating and rotating
in an inertial frame O, capital
X, capital Y, capital Z.
And I need to be
able to describe
the position and the
velocity of this rigid body,
and a point on this
rigid body, which I'll
call B, which might
actually even be moving
with respect to the rigid body.
So the position of
this reference frame
in System I-- this is Notation
System I-- we designate
as R of A in reference frame
O. And the O is in superscript
that precedes the R.
Point B is R of B in
O. And this vector
is R of B with respect
to A. And we write it B.
And with respect to
A is a superscript.
So this essentially,
the superscript version
of the notation.
We do the same thing in
a slightly different way
in which we say with
respect to is a slash.
So A, with respect
to frame O, is
written RA/O. Point B
is RB/O. And the vector
that goes from A
to B is R of B/A.
So the two are
exactly equivalent.
And we'll go one step farther.
And that is to take the time
derivative of this vector B
and use it to derive expressions
for velocities in a rotating
and translating frame.
The position RB, for
example, using this notation,
with respect to O,
is RA with respect
to O plus RB with respect to A.
So it's just a vector sum,
this vector plus this vector
equals that vector.
And we want to take the time
derivative of this expression
for RB with respect to
O. And it will give us
an expression for the velocity
of point B with respect
to the O frame.
And here, I've written this
out in both notation systems.
So in the notation system where
we use slash O as the with
respect to, the velocity
of B, with respect to O,
would be the velocity
of that frame,
translational velocity
of A with respect to O,
plus the time derivative of the
vector RB with respect to A.
And that time derivative must
be taken in the inertial frame,
So /O.
This term expands
into two pieces.
So this is equal to, again,
V of A with respect to O,
but now a derivative of RBA,
with respect to the A frame.
This is as if you were
sitting on that rigid body.
Is that vector getting
any longer or shorter?
Plus the rotation, omega of
the body with respect to O
cross-product with RBA.
I've left out underscores
here to emphasize
that these are vectors.
But these are all vectors.
And in the alternative
notation system,
the /Os become superscripts.
So the velocity of B
and O is the velocity
of A with respect to
O plus the velocity
as seen from the
point of view of being
on the rigid body plus-- this
is the contribution to velocity
as seen in the
inertial frame caused
by the rotation of the body.
And that's the two
different notation systems.
And you'll see these used
on solutions to problems.
You'll see them in
either of the two
frames are either of the
two notation systems.
And you will see these notation
systems used in lecture
and in these recitations.